موضوع للبعض او لنقل الكثير من هو صعب
البلع والتماشي معه الاتحاد الاوروبي يعطي
الدواء الاخضر لمزيد من الحشرات التي تدخل
قوائم الطعام والمنتجات
الصراصير المنزليه منزوعه الدهن يرقات
الديدان قرار ياتي بعد اعتماد الهيئه
الاوروبيه لسلامه الاغذيه بغرض تعزيز
الانظمه الغذائيه المستدامه لكن القواعد
تنص علينا
بوضوح الى استخدام الحشرات في مكوناتها
فالاعتماد بشكل اكبر على بروتين الحشرات
يمكن ان يخفض من نسب الغازات الدفيئه
والاحتباس الحراري لكن المهمه الاصعب
اقناع الناس بتخلي عن نفورهم وتغيير
نظرتهم اتجاهها قبول تناول تلك الانواع
حيث ثلاثه ارباع المستهلكين غير مستعدين
لاستبدال اللحوم بالحشرات وفقا لتقديرا عن
المنظمات المستهلك الاوروبيه وحاليا تنظر
المفوضيه الاوروبيه في ثمانيه طلبات
امراه اخرى قبل الموافقه على اعتمادك غذاء
لكن للتغذى على الحشرات تاريخ قديم نتعرف
عليه في الشرح الثاني
ما هو هذا الشرح الذي يتحدث بحسب منظمه
الاغذيه والزراعه فاو فالحشرات تشكل جزءا
من النظم الغذائيه التقليديه لما لا يقل
عن مليار شخص حول العالم عبر 2009 نوع
مختلف تناول الحشرات ليس امرا مستحداثا في
الواقع هو غذاء شائع منذ الاف السنين
الامريكيون الاصليون مثلا تغدوا على طحين
الجراد الرومان اليونانيون القدماء كانوا
يحبون اكل يرقات الخنافس النمل القاطع
الورق يعتبر من الاطعمه الفاخره في
كولومبيا والبرازيل وتباع مثل بوب كورن في
بعض صلاه السنه وهو مثلا اما في المكسيك
فهنا نحو
550 نوع من الحشرات القابله للاكل وبيض
النمل هناك يعامل بنفس احترام الكافيار
مثلا ديدان القز تؤكل في الصين واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه وتضاف الى الاطباق
التقليديه وخنفسه سوسه النخيل الحمراء هي
نوع من الاطعمه الشهيره في هو الجنوب شرق
اسيا
[موسيقى]